hi my name is dr. Aneesa Ramirez welcome
to my lab at Yale University I'd like to
talk to you a little bit about some of
the science in the Space Shuttle when
you rub your hands together friction
causes your palms to heat up when the
Space Shuttle re-enters our atmosphere
friction causes the bottom of the Space
Shuttle to heat up to during reentry
Space Shuttle experiences temperatures
on the order of 3,000 degrees Fahrenheit
that's about 1650 degrees Celsius these
temperatures are hot enough to liquefy a
metal how is it able to sustain these
high temperatures what prevents it from
heating up the answer is a simple a sand
a special type of sand called silica
which is just sand that's processed is
created in the form of a tile and it's
put at the bottom of the Space Shuttle
and it prevents the Space Shuttle from
heating up it helps it survive these
very high temperatures there's over
27,000 of these tiles at the bottom of
Space Shuttle not only can they
withstand high temperatures they also
prevent heat from spreading they don't
conduct heat they have a low thermal
conductivity so that means that a hot
spot is going to stay in place think of
it this way if I had a metal spoon and
we're to put it into very very hot tea
eventually that spoon is going to heat
up and it may be uncomfortable for me to
touch it metals conduct or spread heat
however ceramics like the tile and the
Space Shuttle don't conduct heat and so
that's why it's able to stay cool let's
look at the Space Shuttle tile in action
here's the Space Shuttle tile and here's
a blowtorch I'm gonna heat up the Space
Shuttle tile and you're gonna see that
it gets red hot watch this
you can see that red spot that's a
really hot spot on the Space Shuttle
pile if you don't believe it's hot watch
this wow that tile is hot because when
the water hits the surface its sizzled
but that's not the end of the story
watch this I can also pick it up because
it doesn't spread heat the center is
still hot but it's still cool for me to
touch
trust me I'm glad about this or else my
fingers would be hurting right now so as
you can see the Space Shuttle tile is
one of the many marbles that has made
the space shuttle program successful for
the last 30 years I'm Aneesa Ramirez
thanks for joining me in my lab at Yale
University and I hope that you'll join
us again for another material marvel